we had a low crazy stuff going on at the
end of season two that was quite some
two part finale wasn't it and I want to
know what do you want to see happen for
fits going forward and what about
Simmons as well
you know what I'm I'm not really sure
where it's gonna go you know I mean I
mean Elizabeth said very early on we
weren't sure about the romantic nature
of the relationship but obviously it's
kind of steering down that road so I'm
not sure like I think they did at the
they did a lot with those characters as
she had helped them grow up and mature a
lot you know I think the big thing in
season 1 was the idea of bravery or
courage and what that meant to them
separately and and them and they've kind
of grown separately in this season in
different paths and then kind of come
back together so it would be Ventura
stand see what they did I've kind of no
idea so I wouldn't like to speculate but
it's interesting that the artifact
normally that's only reacted to Inhumans
in the past and of course we saw what
happened with her in the end this time
so what do you think about Lance and
what would you like to see happen that's
quite a theory I'm not sure there's I
mean I have we've been speculating to
the writers before well as soon as we
read it exactly what that's going to be
in stuff and we came nor close by what I
understand so I'm not sure what I think
they did let's say they've got something
pretty cool plan though so I'm sure
we'll be good yeah obviously as a
newcomer to the series been a big hit
with fans but I'm curious looking into
the future as well where would you like
to see your character go because he does
have a bit of a background in the
comments as well I don't know I kind of
think the hunt is quite an independent
spirit so I think whatever whatever he
does going forward obvious he's got you
know the whole thing with Bob what's
happened to Bobby at the end of the
season that he's gonna probably be
vengeful for all you know perhaps he's
kind of like right let's go out here
kind of thing because you know he's he's
as I say quite an independent spirit so
I think whatever he get hit whatever
he's gonna be up to I think he's
probably gonna be kind of few little
tricks up his sleeve do you know I mean
I think he's probably really quite um
what's the word slightly undercover
about whatever he does I don't know
though who knows what they've got in
store we'll get there and it'll all be
completely different because it's always
just so many surprises when pickup
grip so I'm excited to hear what their
plans are obviously is a big increase in
the complex world it'd be really nice
together just for you guys it's what you
think your character brings to that
universe specifically I know you can say
well how that brings quality than no one
else has let me just say that right here
he there's a seitan where he's very like
blase he'll die you know he likes a good
drink you don't see many cat like for
instance when we had like that kind of
he's the kind of Action Man I suppose of
our show in a lot of ways but they've
put a different Simon you don't see many
characters like that that have portrayed
like that so that's kind of a cool thing
and what would you like to see happening
with all these inhuman powers that are
coming to the fore so much in the show
now going forward in season three if you
could say the writers I would love to
have this happen or any other characters
come into the show what would it be
any power what mean if we got the power
what would you like to see happen within
humans as well just like they could
bring peace and love and abundance to
all human beings and we could just bask
in the glory of humanity yeah well peace
do you think that's gonna happen though
with people like Ward around yeah you
know it's definitely happening yeah I
could say ward yeah easy it's a big baby
that guy just Kiba science just a very
complex scientific question it's a big
deal yeah who support the show from day
one and can't wait to condition and what
have you got to say as well yeah how
very ghosts
you